il ya vous voulez y aller pourquoi que
vous y êtes allé pourquoi déjà pour se
rendre compte
d'après ce que j'ai entendu la pagani
passation dans la pari de la semaine
précédente
aussi pour représenter notre notre
région donc voilà donc on n'a plus la
possibilité d'y aller à moindre frais
parce que au départ on espérait pour la
plusieurs mais bon c'est pas évident
ainsi les gens manifestent c'est la
vision des pommes d'argent donc c'est
pas nous donne plus d'argent pour
refaire un trouvé moyen de transport
pour se déplacer à paris donc nous on a
tous les jeux c'était un moyen de le
placard à moindre coût pour l aller et
donc voila c'était pour se rendre compte
de mon campus il annonçait le castanet
bay a annoncé qu'ils aient la
possibilité de manifester champs elysées
encadré avec filtrage présentation de
canettes et fouillé banque allait faire
manifestations pacifiques des gens clean
mineurs sans réagir sans armes sans
kazan donc nous c'est celui qu'on aime
faire comme ici manifestations
pacifiques que vous êtes arrivé qu'hier
on a les environs vers 10h30 donc il n'y
avait pas grand monde à berlin
sas a convergé de partout des gens de
toute la france est arrivé est donc
arrivé aux champs elysées on n'a jamais
pu pénétrer sur les champs elysées à
chaque achat qu il comprenait
personnalisé aux champs elysées avait
ici reste barrès était barrée ou
prétendent qu'on montait montait jusqu'à
ce qu'on arrive au boulevard haussmann
et donc besoin de semaine on est arrivé
il y avait
aux alentours de 250 da silva rossmann
des individus effectivement qui ne
semblaient pas correspondre les légendes
qui était même pas du tout les jours les
deux bombes devant nous ils nous on va
dire justement une centaine elle quand
on a tenu la tête
remontant le boulevard haussmann des
autres manches on entend des milliers de
jeunes déjà à cette heure là qui monte
est tout à fait pacifiquement avec à
l'arrière des crs qui ont à dire les ai
remontés pas donc après tout ce monde-là
arrivants contacté dès que j'estimais
sur les casseurs de la suite des
événements elles sont montées d'un cran
de l'arc de triomphe
et puis là donc je fais des films mois
plus de la fumée les satyres satire
kitty
qu'est ce qu'il se passe dans ses portes
et des gilets jaunes qui cherchent à
partir sur les côtés pour s'évader de
comme nous a d'ailleurs essayé de
s'évader de cette souricière
mais bloque tout près rue les rues
perpendiculaires bloqués nous nous la
chance de tomber sur une personne
résidente qui nous indiquaient par où
elle se sourire vous l'avez senti cette
tension qui le matin cette tension pas
du tout nous quand on est remonté au
furet vision rencontrer d'autres gilet
jaune qu'il parlait qui remonte avec
nous on cherchait donc pour aller
manifester pacifiquement
on sentait aucune tension franchement
aucune tension c'est simplement qu'après
pourquoi avoir dit vous allez en la
possibilité de manifester
celui censé encadrer donc effectué après
il n'a pu venir et vous étiez pas où
vous auriez été parqués en charrie au
moins il y avait des gens qui voulaient
manifester pacifiquement et les autres
nous aurait été maintenu à l'excès c'est
que j'ai été piégé je sais pas ils vont
nous annoncer des paquets de 15 cents il
ya un mois de ça qu'on avait 15 sans
casse
10 au matin on attendait quand son
cancer 300 gilet jaune c'était c'est
ridicule et les cas ce n'est qu'un temps
quand ce même s'il y en a un sens
c'était facile à maîtriser que dd
michelli gens là d'après eux d'aider des
milliers de gilles et jo méchant c'est
par rapport à ce que vous avez lu c'est
parce qu'on le compte rendu que vous
entendez comme vous étiez sur place vous
par rapport ce que vous avez vu dans vos
yeux
oui c'est parce qu il n'a jamais jamais
pourtant j'y suis l'information sur mu
mon portable
c'est parce que j'avais nombre après
effectivement après ça les gilets jaunes
se sont écartés en différents groupes
dans paris on en a coupé plusieurs mecs
qui marchait tout à fait pacifiquement
mais je n'ai pas bon après on a vu des
images n'étaient plus sur paris après il
fallait convaincre
on a mis des images avec de la casse des
choses inadmissibles
c'est inadmissible on ne peut pas voir
on va cautionner ça c'est impossible
mais bon ça fesse et voilà c'est que les
et le mouvement rouge et jaune
qui je pense sa majorité sur la france
et pacifiste a pas eu d'autres villes on
entendu des problèmes aussi ces casseurs
étaient identifiables
moi quand on avait sous les chants
sincèrement là au départ la
manifestation
j'ai pas au goût de la journée ça va
être compliqué vous n'est pas la
manifestation
moi quand je suis arrivé au dessus du
boulevard haussmann en 150 boulevard
haussmann ils étaient une centaine d
équipement gilet jaune et sur le profil
sur leurs champs les gens c'est parce
qu'il chante et on danse hélène s'est
identifiée et il y avait donc les
dépenses ça fait partie du réseau
africain sur les toits il ya vingt
hélicoptères et une étape pour
identifier on et la police aussi intégré
dans le groupe 1 en civil c'était facile
à identifier pour on n'intervient pas ce
moment pourquoi on pousse les pacifistes
gilet jaune sur ce groupe
or après effectivement souvent d'alléger
les journées aussi qui pète un câble
après petty qui viennent à faire
du même genre on sait pas un gilet jaune
comme tout le monde que 600 blessés il y
en a qui régissent de différentes
manières et là qui sauvera peut-être
qu'ils deviennent agressifs
donc voilà enfin le mouvement s'amplifie
vous disiez qui est présent de faire des
bulles sur votre sol
ce que j'ai lu hier vous êtes des cieux
c'est leur donne encore plus de force ou
pour m déjà sur le coup franchement ça
m'a si ses pages étaient fichés se sont
à temps mais bon j'imagine n'est pas
qu'une manifestation ne puisse décider
laquelle il avait tiré un trait la fumée
partout je peux vous donner de véhicules
brûlés alors là mais bon c'est que ces
10 m2 mais moi je n'ai pas ça donc après
mois voyons ce qui s'est passé au niveau
de nos dirigeants nous ont promis une
manifestation aux galeries etc s'appelle
sécurisé et voyant que ça a dégénéré
ça me motive faut continuer mouvement
chez nous pacifiquement parce que
arrêter ça voudrait dire que ou rentrer
parce que cherchent ceux qui nous
gouvernent à dire diviser que les gens
elle à ndg les jaunes pense que c'est
les gilets jaunes dans leur majorité
kick-ass qui tapent des monuments
historiques
c'est pas ça les gênait jours c'est pas
dommage que les gens doivent garder les
jeunes et ça motive à continuer le
mouvement tout temps et se résout la
chaussée rue la fao maîtrise padres en
versant pacifique
après effectivement peut-être faire des
actions différentes toujours
pacifiquement prêts puissent pousser
plus ceux qui on demande des choses que
effectivement les commerces des artisans
etc ou les usagers de la route ceux qui
ont mis aux enfants l'école par exemple